can we go to your childhood real quick
a brief stroll
so your mom and dad split up when you
were five
from uh from a younging perspective if
you look at your subconscious
what impact do you think that had on you
informing who you are
as a man as a human being well at the
time
i thought that my father was like a hero
you know he was my dad i think every kid
thinks like that about his dad his dad
is like your dad's your protector your
dad is like the coolest guy in the world
that's what you like
yeah yeah everybody wants to be like
their dad especially if your dad is like
an imposing figure
i remember one time me and my cousin got
in a fight
over nothing it was like over uh
who's tougher king kong or godzilla yeah
over nothing that's an important but
yeah
and uh he's like actual fight actually
oh i punched him in the face and um
uh this is when you were like five yeah
yeah and so which side were you on uh
king kong okay
i was wrong godzilla looks like that's
way bigger yeah got until it's 500 feet
tall and he shoots fire out of his mouth
yeah
are you sure i mean
there's there's an argument to be made
it's not all about size right no there's
no argument to be made 500 feet tall
versus 50 feet tall one's a gigantic
dinosaur one is a stupid monkey who gets
shot down by a plane you know you can't
kill godzilla godzilla no back no
you can't kill godzilla with a plane
like that [ __ ] wouldn't work in godzilla
yeah killed king kong
um
king kong in the new movies kept growing
he's getting bigger and bigger got to
the point where he's as big as godzilla
it just feels like king kong is stronger
oh stop
back tape back take immediate backtake
you don't think there's a backtake
there's a difference if he's the same
size human weapons
and two animals going at it of a
different size you don't think there's
in in the jungle a smaller animal can
take on a bigger animal you got monkey
versus uh
let's see a lion monkey versus a bear
what who wins a monkey versus
not a monkey what's the strongest uh ape
uh girl
no but gorilla see okay gorilla can't do
back takes i'm thinking of like a
smaller
you know what i'm saying because in jiu
jitsu you see this all the time do you
remember that scene in talladega nights
do you know talladega
where the the little boy's talking his
grandpa i'll be all over you like a
spider monkey
exactly a spider monkey i was thinking
all right there's some animals like
here's a better example a wolverine
wolverines chase wolves and bears off of
their kills
and they're not very big at all they're
just so ferocious
and they're so durable like it's very
hard to kill a wolverine yeah and
there's videos of like cats like not
actually like domestic cats
or uh or domestic dogs starting [ __ ]
with much larger animals yeah and if
they're ferocious enough
well pit bulls are a great example that
pit bulls are small like real game bred
pit bulls are like 35 45 pounds and
they'll kill much larger dogs
you